entre photos objets vêtements ou encore
peinture le salon d'exposition de la
mairie de la celle saint cloud est
entièrement refait aux couleurs de la
syrie une exposition authentique aux
senteurs du savon d'alep et des épices
du pays on a aussi bien un savoir faire
artisanal on va essayer de souligner le
travail qui est fait par les mains une
dimension très historique importante
surtout en ce moment on a besoin de
recontextualiser un petit peu l'histoire
de la syrie et ce qui en a fait l'idée
que c'est vraiment un millefeuille
finalement de plein de choses de plein
d'événements et de pleins de
civilisation qui ont laissé peu à peu
des tracés ont construit la syrie
d'aujourd'hui parmi les artistes
symbolique de l'exposition phadia ziggy
un artiste engagé qui vit et travaille à
damas son oeuvre des dessins de premier
abord naïf mais qui représente des
hommes blessés c'est un soutien qu'ils
apportent au peuple libanais en
représentant l'explosion de beyrouth
qu'il y a eu en 2020 c'est de montrer la
solidarité entre les pays notamment
entre le liban et la syrie qui sont très
forts ils ont des liens très puissant
toujours avec l'idée de partager l'art
d'utiliser ce médium artistique pour
s'engager pour aussi montré du
militantisme et soutenir les peuples une
seconde exposition est en place à la mjc
de la celle-saint-cloud des caricatures
du dessinateur annie abbas d'autres
événements plus ponctuelles sont prévues
le 4 et 5 décembre je vous invite
également à venir participer au marché
de noël dans laquelle seront mis en
vente certains produits ici présents
dans des segments dellape le livre
passionnant qui nous fait voyager en
syrie
une nuit de l'api de la nuit de la piste
sèche nous à base l'événement se
terminera le 12 décembre avec au salon
d'exposition des comptes précités par la
comédienne et auteure travelling et
parra